let's pick up our conversation with Dave
Rubin host of the political talk show
the Rubin report on YouTube so I thought
it would be interesting Dave to talk a
little bit about because you're
increasingly not doing this on your show
deliberately as you talked about in
order to stay away from the sort of
24-hour news cycle generally speaking
were six months in month into the Trump
administration how do you assess this
presidency so far you know I think it's
unfortunately it's become so polarizing
even talking about Trump that making an
assessment that's a clear honest
assessment no matter how you do it
you're gonna you're going to get some
hysterical stuff but I'll do the best I
can
yeah so first off just to be clear I did
not vote for Trump I voted for Gary
Johnson and I should be judged
accordingly I did videos on how to stop
from I talk to people that I admire at
the highest level such as Sam Harris on
why you shouldn't vote for Trump and
what his fears were from the week before
the election I had Hillary Rosen on who
is a progressive pundit and does tons of
work with the DNC about why she hated
Trump then I had plenty of Trump not
plenty of Trump people but I had a
couple Trump people on including Scott
Adams who I think was the best public
advocate for if you wanted to vote for
Trump why to vote anyway I did not vote
for him my feeling was after after the
election my feeling was that the the
fact that the chessboard as I described
before has been thrown up and everyone's
revaluated things versus that if Hillary
had been elected the screws that had
about all the stuff that we talked about
about mainstream media and the corrupt
politicians and all this stuff those
screws would have been tightened it
would have been really bad for
independent media people it would have
been bad for just the slow degradation
of society that we're seeing and
discourse what all the screws would have
been tightened against us so Trump
although I did not support him by
throwing this chess board up or driving
the truck through it or whatever you
want to use to describe it I think that
has created a net good in that right now
there are more people talking about
politics reevaluating what they think
getting engaged whether for him or
against them then I've sir
be seen in my lifetime okay so let's
pause there briefly because you just now
were you've just said a lot I think
you're about to get to the part where
we're going to disagree but so far
you've said something I've been saying
for a while which is if Hillary Clinton
had won we would have seen significantly
lower engagement in politics you would
have seen many on the Left sort of say
hey we've got a Democrat in the White
House so we can sort of tune out for
four years which would have led to a
disaster in the 2018 midterms and the
reality is that as someone who was a
center to center right in Hillary
Clinton which I believed her to be I
think it actually would have not been
particularly good for the left which I
consider myself to be a part on so so
far I agree with you the Trump
presidency and the what I see as the
endless scandals have really
reinvigorated activism in an interesting
way not exactly what you said but I'm
sort of agreeing with you here yeah and
and I think that that's all legit and
also you know that fits within the
things that I care about the things that
I care about are talking about the idea
is talking about the principles again
not necessarily every day-to-day
decision or monitoring his Twitter so
that I can start getting outraged
because now there's you know there's
media companies that literally spend all
day waiting for him to tweet so they can
write about how outraged everyone is so
they're doing pre outrage before people
even have a chance for it now as far as
the actual presidency I guess we should
spend a minute on on Russia first just
because that's what everybody seems to
go to now look it seems to me that they
haven't been able to pin anything
directly you know a month ago it was all
the Comey stuff that didn't seem to work
out two weeks ago as all the Trump jr.
stuff that didn't seem to work out this
week I guess there's some metaphoric
stuff we'll see if that works out if if
we were to go on the assumption for a
second I'll do it both ways for you if
we're going on the assumption that Trump
did somehow crude with Russia then what
you're saying is that technically we
should be at war with Russia right now
that you'd have to then depose Trump and
of course pence and then I guess you
then install the Speaker of the House
Paul Ryan now in a lot of ways by doing
that you'd have a worse person for the
Democrats because Paul Ryan by most
estimations especially economically is
certainly to the right of Trump and
maybe on some social stuff yeah but Dave
let me I don't want to I don't want to
enter
up you but only because we've done the
Russia stuff up and down I'm more
curious like for example on the stuff
Trump has actually done like not whether
he colluded with Russia but what is
there like a particular policy or
something Trump has done that you think
is really good and or what has he done
that you think is is really a disaster
if there's anything like what do you see
is the highs and lows of the six months
yeah just give me 30 seconds on the
Russian thing I can wrap that up though
because my point is that if you're
saying that there was collusion or they
knew about us we are in effect at war I
mean could there possibly be a bigger
act of war than installing a president
so what you're saying is that it would
then be President Ryan where we have to
lead you an election and get Hillary I
mean the first thing we would have to do
is go to war with Russia
I do not want to go to war with Russia I
don't think there's any reason to go to
war with Russia but hypothetically did
would you say going to war with Russia
is so bad that we should allow an
illegitimate president if it were
determined to be such no okay all right
okay they did good yeah no I believe in
evidence and logic and reason so if one
day if tomorrow literally the second I
hang up with you right now if I go on
Twitter and they say well we figured it
out we actually got the tail
it's figured out Trump was installed or
the Russian government actually colluded
and then we had to go ahead and do that
well then of course I don't want a
Russian puppet but all I'm saying is you
need evidence yeah and I think we have a
lot more Ferrier than evidence okay so
that's one thing as to your other
question the specific to the policy look
when George W Bush was president I was
against the executive actions when when
Obama was president I was against
executive action when Trump who's now
used a ton of them I've been against
them we have three branches of
government we can do a little Poli Sci
101 the legislative branch is supposed
to write the laws the executive branch
signs them into law that the president
and then of course the Supreme Court or
the court systems figure out if these
laws are legal the idea that we're doing
so much through the executive branch I
think is horrific for for democracy and
for the rural law and for how this
country is supposed to operate so the
fact that he is so willing to do that
and by the way it shows you the
limitations of this silliness so when
Obama did all this stuff with a
chronic pain or whatever he did uh well
guess what it all because it didn't go
through the legislative process it all
got reversed by Trump with the sign of
that same pen so I think the deferment
of power which by the way is there's
everyone's culpable in this we the
people are but Congress which doesn't
pass laws anymore and doesn't have real
debates and really figure out what
they're trying to do they're they're
very good at investigating themselves
and investigating other branches of
government but they don't seem to be
able to pass laws and function the way
that they're supposed to and be the
representatives of the people that
they're supposed to be so that my main
issue with him is that obviously you
Trump is a wild card and that I don't
know what the Trump political ethos is
other than it's it's for Trump I get yo
there's this make America great again or
you know drain the swamp or all those
things but that to me is not a political
ethos I care about ideas I care I want
someone to come in and say these are the
these are the principles that I believe
in and this is how I'm going to try to
govern and I simply don't know what that
is I don't know what Trump's moral
center is if there was a real crisis you
know if there was a horrible terrorist
attack or if there was a missile crisis
with North Korea tonight
he's trumped the the level-headed person
you want dealing with this now you can
probably and his people would make an
argument that he's put in people like
mattis that that would do these things
well and and he would defer to them
okay that's possible but my biggest
issue with him is that I just don't know
what his political beliefs truly are
other than sort of a day to day
machinations of playing the media and
playing that fight and I don't think
that that's great for democracy but has
a nice beyond anything like his tax
policy proposal or what it is that he
seemingly wants although who really
knows it seems like he doesn't even now
it seems he confused health insurance
with life insurance this entire time but
what he claims to want to do about
health insurance or whatever is there
any policy idea that he's put forth that
you say that's what I disagree with the
most it's a disaster
well the tax stuff I don't particularly
disagree with I this is as I we started
the interview I said I've shifted a
little right on taxes I believe you have
the right to
keep as much as you earn as much as you
can as you are now I do believe we need
to pay into the system to have roads and
social services and things like that
which by the way there are some
libertarians who don't I think this is
something that you could couch in that
classical liberal Avenue but but
lowering taxes as a general rule
I'm completely for even if it's in a way
even if it's in a way that would be bad
for the economy um well I well you have
to you know I guess what I mean that's
sort of vague I mean what what I mean is
there we have nothing we can point to
that suggests sort of supply-side
stimulus by tax cuts for the very rich
is good for the economy we have periods
where it's been done and it hasn't been
acutely bad but there's no period
there's there's no evidence that it's
good so for me I would say okay there's
the question of what's ethical or moral
and there's also the question of the
economic impact of it that's sort of my
background so I would say it's hard for
me to support something that would be
economically damaging well I don't know
that there's any direct evidence that
it's economically damaging but also we
would have to widdle through and we
could do this in a week or so if you
want we'd have to widdle through exactly
what the tax plan said but again as a
general rule I want you David Pakman as
a small business owner which you are
with employees to pay the least amount
of taxes that you can so that you can
hire more people so that you can build a
better studio so that you can invest
more in your operation and bring the
goodness that is you and your operation
out there I know this as a small
businessman now if I had been being
taxed higher right now I admitted
capital costs to build this studio and
do all this stuff by the way I pay a
hundred percent of my employees health
insurance a hundred percent I also give
my director gets a gets a cut of our
YouTube bread I do all the things I try
to put my beliefs into practice but
that's a confusion for me Dave because
if those capital expenses are tax
deductible so if the tax rate goes up
for you as an individual if you've got
pass-through income or for the business
tax rate it doesn't matter what the
business tax rate is is if you want to
spend money on capital because that you
don't pay taxes on that actually it
encourages you to spend money on
epital to have a higher tax rate um so I
under I understand what that argument is
and I would argue at the same time as
that yeah that having every one of us
every one of us whether you whether you
whatever however much you earn it is
your money it is your money we get taxed
in all kinds of other ways with sales
tax and everything else I pay payroll
tax and blah blah blah and I would say
the best way to if you right now if
you're on the left or you're a
progressive and you hate Trump and you
hate what this government has become I
don't think that the best answer is to
topple the government and destroy this
incredibly experiment which is what it
is this American experiment I don't
think the best way is to destroy I think
the best way is to rein in the power
that it has over us and one of the ways
you can do that is by giving it less
money I think that the government could
function a lot slimmer and trimmer I
think most people I think actually you
could probably get most progressives to
admit that that government is a giant
waste but often they'll tell you how
much they hate the government and then
the solution is more or more taxes I
would say the only way to really control
this stuff is to is to tighten the
strings on the finances and you have the
right to or keep as much as possible of
what you are fair enough and that's more
more of an ethical argument than an
economic one I think you would agree I
would have to look at the eye
I suppose in this case I'm making the
ethical argument which I think if things
were more done on the grounds of ethics
yeah
then sort of staring at numbers and
projecting things and the CBO which
projects things for 20 years and it's
always wrong about everything or all the
pundits who project things are always
wrong and all the polls that are always
wrong I think doing some things based on
ethical principles might actually have
some more long-term positive benefits to
society all right let's pause there
we'll be back for our few remaining
moments with Dave Rubin host of the
political show the Rubin report on
YouTube back after this